bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre ce matin
les débats des sénateurs portant sur le
septennat non renouvelable c'est une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle du
patron un des sénateurs du groupe rdse
ce groupe à majorité des radicaux de
gauche jacques mézard jacques mézard qui
estime qu' il faut revenir au septennat
renouvelables que le quinquennat a porté
préjudice à la fonction présidentielle
selon lui et bien désormais le président
de la république est incapable
d'incarner le pouvoir d'état le temps
présidentiel s'est aligné sur le temps
médiatique et tout cela nuit au débat
démocratique
rappelons qu'en même temps à l'assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi
semblable a également été déposé et
signé par des députés de tous bords
aussi bien des ump que des centristes
que quelques élus front national
on le voit le départ n'épargne aucun
parti bref en cette période de véritable
crise institutionnelle et où de nombreux
élus réclament l'avènement de la sixième
république le chef de l'état n'est pas
épargné très loin de là tout de suite
donc retour à ce débat qui s'est tenu
mardi au sénat c'est jacques mézard qui
commence la discussion lui qui est
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues réfléchir
sur l'évolution des institutions est
légitime pour une assemblée
parlementaire et pour le sénat
considérer aujourd'hui que le
fonctionnement des institutions ne
poserait pas de problèmes me paraît
quelque chose de non raisonnable et
d'ailleurs il suffit de constater que
sur tous les bancs sur tout les centres
dans toutes les sensibilités politiques
le débat existe
il est naturel il est légitime et notre
groupe a souhaité que ce débat puisse
commencer de manière formelle devant
notre haute assemblée rappelle que à
l'issue du référendum tenu le 24
septembre 2000 qui avait été marqué par
le triomphe de l'abstention puisqu'il
faut se souvenir qu'à l'époque 74 7% des
inscrits n'avaient pas voté la loi
constitutionnelle du 2 octobre 2000
établissant le quinquennat mettez fin à
une tradition constitutionnelle en
vigueur depuis 1873 c'était un
bouleversement institutionnel qui était
passée presque inaperçue
aujourd'hui les effets pour certains les
méfaits du quinquennat sur l' équilibre
des pouvoirs sont connus et reconnus
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
choisi de remettre cette question dans
l'actualité sommes pas les seuls
d'ailleurs à réfléchir sur les
institutions j'ai vu que le président de
l'assemblée nationale s'y intéresser de
près et avait mis en place un comité
d'ailleurs dans lequel il ya peu de
sénateur et nous avons souhaité et nous
avons souhaité en inscrivant cette
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour de
la haute assemblée que ceux d'emma que
ce débat puisse commencer j'ai constaté
que récemment un certain nombre de
députés avaient déposé une proposition
de loi un peu semblable il ya monsieur
le ministre
aucune corrélation directe entre les
dépôts de ces deux propositions de loi
je ne doute pas que ça vous rassurera
nous avons bien entendu monsieur le
rapporteur
votre argument selon lequel l'image des
parlementaires seraient atteintes par la
réflexion nécessaire sur cette question
mais nous ne pouvons le recevoir
le consensus sur le quinquennat est en
fête
dans l'opinion et dans la vie publique
remis en cause aujourd'hui par la
position difficile de l'institution du
président de la république qui est
soumis à toutes les avanies de
l'actualité au volte face de l'opinion
que l'on sait que nous savons
capricieuse et volage il relève du
courage de nous autre élu de la
république de savoir mener des réformes
même lorsqu'elles ne sont pas ou peu
populaire le philosophe schopenhauer
souligné qu'une fois que l'opinion a eu
pour elle un bon nombre de voix
les suivants pense qu'elle n'a pas pu
les obtenir qu'elle n'a pu les obtenir
que grâce à la justesse de ses
fondements il rajoute les autres sont
alors contraints de reconnaître ce qui
est communément admis pour ne pas être
considérés comme des esprits inquiet
s'insurgeant contre des opinions
universellement admises ou comme des
impertinents
se croyant plus malin que tout le monde
adhérez devient allait alors en devoirs
et nous n'adhérons pas en ce qui nous
concerne un régime factice de l'opinion
du plus grand nombre
par ailleurs je voulais corriger un
point monsieur le rapporteur
pour nous il ne s'agit pas de façon
latente ou avoué d'affaiblir la fonction
du président de la république mais bien
plutôt de lui redonner un statut qu'elle
a perdu en la restaurants dans son rôle
d'arbitré au dessus de la mêlée
l'hypertrophie du président de la
république n'est pas un atout de la
fonction
contrairement à ce qui pourrait être
pensé surtout dans un régime où
l'exécutif se voudrait bicéphale
j'ajoute que je m'adresse la aux
rapporteurs que je ne doute pas vu sa
sensibilité politique et je salue
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois que l'on lorsqu'on reprend les
propos
du général de gaulle sur le septennat et
la non comme concomitance de l'élection
des députés et du président de la
république on s'aperçoit là que la mise
en place du quinquennat est à l'encontre
totalement de la volonté initiale de
celui qui a voulu la vème république
nous ne sommes d'ailleurs pas les seuls
à nous inquiéter de cet affaiblissement
de la fonction présidentielle je les dis
d'autres parlementaires il y a quelques
jours ont déposé un texte assez
semblable mais le débat se justifie pour
nous par l'ampleur des dégâts du
quinquennat dans le régime de la vème
république
c'est cet argument que je considère
comme fallacieux qui a été avancé qui ne
peut nous être opposé les douze années
de quinquennat nous donne désormais le
recul nécessaire pour faire aujourd'hui
un bilan d'une réforme
ce bilan n'a pas à être positif car il
faut savoir reconnaître ses erreurs et
celle de ses prédécesseurs
cela ne fonctionne pas bien et il
faudrait que nous nous en contentons je
ne crois pas que ce soit une bonne façon
de faire évoluer les institutions
pour notre part nous ne souhaitons pas
adopté ce type de considération pour le
moins défaitiste et immobiliste notre
république
n'at-elle pas sans cesse besoin d'être
adapté moderniser améliorer c'est ce que
l'on n'aura pas rabâche d'ailleurs à
longueur de semaines et de mois
donc s'il est un domaine dans lequel il
faut savoir évoluer
je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent il
faut une sixième république
nous disons nous simplement et ainsi il
ya un système qui mérite une évolution
je rappelle d'ailleurs que dans la vème
république il ya eu des évolutions
considérables déjà avant le quinquennat
en 1960 2 il ya eu une évolution
considérable c'est l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel
je ne fais pas partie d'un groupe qui a
soutenu
oh que cette élection au suffrage
universel et en relisant ce qui m'est
arrivé quand même un certain nombre de
fois les discours du président ma mère
ville j'y voyais régis lisez ces mots
qui sont quand même extrêmement clairs
et qu'ils ont annoncés bien des
vicissitudes de la vème république
président monnerville en 1962 disait
réunir en une seule en une seule main
sur une seule tête tous les pouvoirs
sans nulle contrepoids c'est proprement
abolir la démocratie il faut dire que il
s'adressait aux français et il
s'adressait aux français avec un texte
qui avait pour titre la constitution et
violet le peuple et abuser nous avons vu
la suite et je vous conseille mes chers
collègues de relire un certain nombre de
ses discours
surtout ceux d'ailleurs de 62 et de 1969
ils sont assez prémonitoire de ce qui
est devenu la cinquième république
quand on voit l'historique de la
question de la durée du mandat
présidentiel
le quinquennat a été effectivement une
question récurrente dans la vie
politique et institutionnelle de la vème
république de georges pompidou à
françois mitterrand en passant par
jacques chirac et son premier ministre
lionel jospin qui a réactivé la question
2000 la durée du mandat présidentiel a
suscité constamment des débats
près de trois quinquennats plus tard
nous pouvons dire aujourd'hui que son
instauration a considérablement modifié
la pratique de nos institutions issues
de la constitution du 4 octobre 1958
sans que les conséquences majeures de
cette modification a priori minime est
présenté comme minime à l'époque était
est perçue est prise en compte
adoptée dans la quasi-indifférence de
nos concitoyens le remplacement du
septennat par le quinquennat a en
réalité constitué un bouleversement
institutionnel constitutionnel dont nous
mesurons les uns et les autres depuis
quelques années
les conséquences souvent dommageables
car quelles sont les conséquences de
l'instauration du quinquennat dans la
vie politique actuelle le quinquennat
qui est aussi appelée présidence de
législature par la concomitance de
l'élection du président de la république
suivi de l'élection des députés a mis
fin au statut particulier d'arbitré
institutionnel qui était celui du
président de la république et qui était
la volonté expresse des rédacteurs de la
constitution de la vème république le
fondement même de la constitution du
cinquième de la vème république et en
particulier l'article 5
mon excellent collègue rapporteur
l'article 5
c'est de faire du président de la
république à un arbitre au dessus des
partis
on sait d'ailleurs ce que penser des
parties l'illustrent personnage qui
avait mis en place cette constitution et
il faut ainsi souligné que les
constitution de la vème république
constituants de la vème république
concevez la durée de la fonction
présidentielle
clé de voûte des institutions en
fonction de son importance et de la
conception de l'équilibré trouvé entre
les différents pouvoirs
c'est la position qui est consacré par
l'article 5
le président de la république veille au
respect de la constitution
il assure par son arbitrage le
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics ainsi que la continuité de
l'état
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale de l'intégrité du territoire
et du respect des traités mais
brandissant le spectre de la
cohabitation
les partisans du quinquennat issus
d'ailleurs des différentes sensibilités
sont parvenus à imposer leurs vues
réfutant la souveraineté des électeurs
qui en 1986 1993 et 1997 avait choisi de
leur plein arbitres de confier le destin
national à une majorité différente
on verra d'ailleurs si avec le
quinquennat ça peut arriver
or le quinquennat ne semble pas avoir
une nouvelle fois réglée la question de
cette configuration institutionnelle
la cohabitation est et sera toujours
possible tant que le président de la
république disposera du droit de
dissolution monsieur le rapporteur
si l'on voulait empêcher toute
cohabitation
il aurait alors fallu supprimer
l'article 12 de la constitution plutôt
que d'instaurer le quinquennat car un
des vrais problèmes du fonctionnement de
la constitution aujourd'hui nos
institutions
ces censures et dissolution par rapport
au quinquennat et il faudra bien il
faudra bien avoir ce débat il est urgent
d' effectuer au nom de l'impératif de la
modernisation des institutions le
remplacement du septennat par le
quinquennat ainsi que l'inversion du
calendrier sont altérées et même
dénaturer la nature constitutionnelle
originel du président de la république
l'alignement de la durée de fonction
présidentielle sur celle de la fonction
parlementaire a mis fin aux privilèges
du président de la république est là
finalement transformé en super élu chef
de la majorité
en lieu et place du premier ministre est
ce que nous vivons ces dernières années
et ces derniers mois en est là claire
illustration
les conclusions du comité ville veut
d'elle en 1993 avait souligné clairement
les contradictions inhérentes au
quinquennat présidentiel
je cite ainsi la réduction de l'exécutif
à la seule personne du président ferait
en réalité de celui ci le véritable
premier ministre or il est singulier de
vouloir tout à la fois réduire dans le
temps les pouvoirs dévolus au chef de
l'état et dans cette durée les renforcer
et les étendre plus encore elle doyen
vedel était en excellent
constitutionnaliste monsieur le
rapporteur lui aussi parfaitement sage
dans ses propos
entre un président de la république chef
de la majorité
et un président de la république
arbitres des institutions est par nature
est responsable il faut choisir comment
dans ces conditions s'étonner de
l'abaissement de la fonction qui est le
corollaire du désenchantement des
citoyens vis-à-vis de leurs institutions
carly paix représente
présidentialisation dont d'aucuns sur
les bancs ici présents ont pu faire le
procès sous le précédent quinquennat et
quinquennat changent mais le problème
reste le même et bien
l'hyperprésident présidentialisation
n'est pas synonyme je les dis d'un
renforcement de l'autorité du président
elle est synonyme de la polarisation de
la vie politique autour d'une
personnalité d'un homme médiatiquement
surexposé et responsables
individuellement des malheurs collectif
de la france l'abaissement de la
fonction au sens où l'entend 9
rapporteur serait donc salvateur pour
cette figure centrale de la vème
république puisque cela lui permettrait
au contraire de retrouver une stature et
une autorité nationale
nous n'avons manifestement pas la même
vision
l'argument de la modernité avancée en
d'autres circonstances et d'autres lieux
a également été celui des défenseurs du
quinquennat qui ont fait valoir
l'accélération de l'histoire ainsi que
l'importance du temps médiatique
la modernité ne peut-elle pourtant
s'accommoder du temps de la réflexion
nécessaire pour mener des réformes
législatives efficace est nécessaire
pour ne pas légiférer par retouché
petits arrangements ce que nous
connaissons quelles que soient les
majorités en place
enfin doit entrer en ligne de compte le
rôle du chef de l'état dans la politique
internationale et notamment son rôle de
représentation
le temps est un facteur essentiel des
relations internationales compte tenu de
l'importance des relations personnelles
entre chefs d'état du fait que de
nombreuses décisions même économiques
sont prises lors de ce sommet le temps
doit conférer au chef de l'état une
expérience mais aussi une autorité
morale
et un pouvoir d'influencé qui lui
permettent de négocier et d'appuyer ses
revendications
l'exemple d'ailleurs du rôle du couple
franco allemand adenauer de gaulle
schmid giscard d'estaing kohl mitterrand
dans la relance de la construction
européenne est à ce titre révélateur de
la puissance de la durée obligeant le
titulaire de la fonction présidentielle
à se placer dans la position de candidat
à sa succession
parce que ça c'est la réalité que nous
vivons est d'ailleurs l'actualité en
alterné la démonstration le quinquennat
nuit à la qualité du débat politique
tandis qu'il consacre un nouvel
affaiblissement du parlement
le quinquennat a induit dans la
situation temporel la vie politique un
système négatif
la preuve s'il en est besoin nous la
trouvons dans la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui à peine deux
années après l'élection du nouveau
président de la république
les candidats à sa succession dans
l'opposition comme dans la majorité se
sont déjà déclarés les uns après les
autres
nous y voyons une américanisation de la
vie politique avec l'entrée en jeu de la
campagne des primaires trois années
avant l'élection il est souvent
d'ailleurs reproché au président des
états unis en exercice de ne plus être
que le candidat à sa propre succession
les deux dernières années de son mandat
la théorie économique du cycle électoral
a bien illustré ces problématiques
appliqué ainsi à la fonction
présidentielle cette théorie montre que
le titulaire de la fonction
présidentielle
loin de pouvoir arbitrer le destin
national du pays conformément à la
lettre et à l'esprit de la constitution
de 58 se voit obligée d'entrer dans la
mêlée politique dans la perspective très
proche de sa réélection
la conséquence essentielle de cette
nouvelle temporalité et de privilégier
le court terme médiatique sur le long
terme et de faire ainsi passer l'intérêt
partisan avant l'intérêt général
enfin l'adoption du quinquennat a eu
pour dommages plus que collatéral celui
de restreindre les marges de la majorité
parlementaire
désormais plus que jamais tenues dans un
rôle de chambre d'enregistrement
des directives du pouvoir exécutif nous
en payons tous les jours le prix fort
après trois quinquennats
le président de la république ne peut
plus aspirer à incarner le pouvoir
d'état le temps présidentiel c'est
finalement aligné sur le temps
médiatique sans que les bienfaits
attendus de cette accélération du temps
politique ne se réalise le maintien du
quinquennat ne pourra se faire qu'au
détriment de l'intérêt national
notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle prévoit donc de
revenir à la durée initiale du mandat
présidentiel à savoir le septennat pour
un strict équilibre des institutions
nous ne vous proposons pas de supprimer
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel
ce serait un pas difficile dans les
circonstances actuelles d'empêcher
l'exercice de deux mandats présidentiels
consécutifs au vu de sa durée il
convient de donner 700 cette année on
peut mener une politique dans la liberté
en étant moins soumis aux aléas des
différentes élections
il s'agit pas d'un retour en arrière
comme le rapporteur a pu le faire valoir
nous ne souhaitons pas revenir au
septennat renouvelables qui a d'ores et
déjà montré ses limites le septennat non
renouvelables constituent une forme
d'adaptation à la modernité et à sa
temporalité particulière le comité veut
d'elle avait lui-même mis en avant les
avantages d'un tel dispositif en
considérant que la durée de 7 ans
convient au développement d'un projet
appuyé sur une majorité et lui suffit en
même temps que l'importance et la nature
des pouvoirs confiés au chef de l'état
restitue à la fonction arbitrale tout
son sens si son titulaire ne peut se
présenter à nouveau au suffrage enfin
que l'autorité du président de la
république en matière internationale
gagnerait à l'accomplissement d'un seul
septennat je crois que c'était à
l'époque et c'est toujours une réflexion
pleine de sagesse
la fonction ne serait plus atteintes par
les biais du cycle électoral bien connu
des économistes tout en retrouvant une
dignité et une sérénité nécessaire
dans l'art de gouverner voilà mes chers
collègues l'objet de cette excellente
proposition de loi constitutionnelle que
nous vous demandons de voter merci
monsieur le président mézard monsieur
une porte les rapporteurs de la
commission des lois la parole madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président la commission des lois
monsieur le président mes armes et chers
collègues
la proposition de loi constitutionnel
déposée par le présent mézard et son
groupe et est une proposition sur max et
les rentes en tout cas très intéressante
au moins pour une raison c'est qu'elle
nous permet de poursuivre et non pas
d'ouvrir un débat qui dure depuis 1958 à
savoir celui non seulement de la
fonction présidentielle mais du cadre
temporel dans lequel elle s'exerce
d'abord un point de rappel et de
comparaison puisque la question du
retour au septennat pose la question
évidemment des raisons pour lesquelles
le quinquennat a été adopté le septennat
d'abord rappelons que le septennat
ce n'est pas au départ une tradition
républicaine
c'est un compromis passé entre les deux
traditions dynastique qui se
partageaient la la querelle de savoir
qui exercerait le pouvoir politique en
france dans les années 1870 et ce
compromis dynastique a porté sur sept en
ces temps le temps nécessaire pour
régler la question de la durée de vie
présumé du comte de chambord et donc le
compromis de 1873 a été ensuite
introduit dans les institutions de la
troisième république
tout simplement pour une raison c'est
que
lorsque les républicains sont devenus
majoritaires et lorsqu'ils ont vidé la
fonction présidentielle de sang contenu
politique et bien le fait que le
président de la république soit élu pour
sept ans n'avait plus grande importance
est donc ce qui était au départ un
compromis deux circonstances est devenu
une tradition
tout simplement parce que il n'y avait
plus d'objets pour la querelle est donc
on a gardé le septennat
on a gardé le septennat et lorsqu en
1946 après avoir évacué premier projet
de constitution
on s'est rangé un retour partiel à la
troisième république avec la
constitution que d'octobre 46 et bien
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a gardé le
septennat dans la conception qui avait
été celle de la pratique de la
république troisième jusqu'en 1940 et
donc vincent auriol rené coty ont été
des président élu pour sept ans mais
avec un pouvoir qui était encore moindre
que celui que celui que détenait le
président de la iiième république et on
arrive en 1958 alors en 1958 faut quand
même se rappeler que lorsque les
rédacteurs de la constitution l'eau
rédigé il savait trois mois vous avez
trois mois pour rédiger la constitution
et la rédaction a été faite dans les
délais les plus brefs de l'histoire
républicaine et il savait pourquoi parce
que si la constitution n'était pas
adopté avant octobre 1958 on revenait on
retourner automatiquement à
l'application de la constitution de la
quatrième république
donc on a été très vite il ya des
parties entières de la constitution qui
ont été reprises de la constitution
antérieur on n'a pas réalisé 2
deux déclarations on a pris un préambule
qui était un copié collé de celui de
1946 on a même sauvegarder les principes
fondamentaux du préambule de 1946 faute
d'avoir le temps de faire autre chose
et quant à la conception de la fonction
présidentielle ce qui était essentiel
pour le général de gaulle c'était
surtout de l'exercer la question du
mandat de sept ans ne s'est pas posée
pourquoi parce que pour les gaullistes à
l'époque il fallait que le mandat dure
longtemps
michel debré pendant la guerre avait
écrit un livre durant lequel il avait
même estimé que la durée idéale d'un
mandat pour un chef d'état était de 12
ans il avait fait la moyenne des grandes
des grands règne de la période d'ancien
régime et il avait trouvé que 12 ans
c'était pas mal et c'est bien que
finalement c'est ans était en quelque
sorte pour lui un pis-aller
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que le septennat donc a été adopté il a
été introduit il a été votée mais dans
la conception du général de gaulle ce
septennat était une durée maximale le
président de la république était élu il
était rigide mais en même temps la
contrepartie de ce mandat de sept ans
c'était la responsabilité politique du
présent la république devant le peuple
et le fait que le présent à public
pouvait à tout moment à l'occasion d'un
référendum notamment demandé au peuple
la question de confiance posez au peuple
la question de confiance et avec la
sanction de démissionner en cas de
réponse négative de l'électorat et c'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est ce qui s'est
passé en 1969 le fameux référendum du 27
avril
53 % non le 28 avril le général de
gaulle démissionne autrement dit d'un
côté vous avez le septennat qui assure
un pilotage à long terme de l'action
publique mais l'autre côté vous avez une
responsabilité permanente du chef de
l'état qui fait qu'à tout moment
celui ci peut être amené à démissionner
lorsqu'il perd la confiance du peuple
c'était la conception du général de
gaulle et dire que c'était étrangers
à l'idée des rédacteurs de la
constitution de 58 évidemment c'est
absolument faux car ce sont les mêmes
qui rédige la constitution et qui la
mettent en oeuvre
ce sont les mêmes qui sont élus c'est le
même qui était lui présent un public en
décembre 1958 et qui ensuite va à trois
reprises utilisé le référendum pour et
bien interroger le peuple sur des
questions essentielles avant qu' ils
soient ré élu au suffrage universel en
donc voilà c'est un ensemble il ya eu il
ya d'une part le texte mais il ya
d'autre part la pratique du texte et les
deux choses sont liées tout simplement
pour par une personne qui est le général
de gaulle qui est à la fois le principal
rédacteur et celui qui met en oeuvre
cette constitution alors bien entendu au
lendemain de la démission du général de
gaulle aucun des présidents de la
république qui ont succédé au général de
gaulle n'a partager cette vision des
choses
aucun à partager cette vision des choses
et du coup la façon dont le septennat a
été mise en oeuvre a changé de nature
elle a changé de nature et ça vous
explique d'ailleurs pourquoi dès 1973 le
successeur du général de gaulle georges
pompidou s'est posé la question de la
réduction du mandat
la question du quinquennat se pose
quasiment dans les années qui suivent le
départ du général de gaulle et la
procédure vous le savez elle a été très
loin puisqu'elle a été adopté cette
révision est adoptée par les chambres
simplement le g le georges pompidou à
bloquer la procédure parce qu'il savait
n'obtiendrait pas la majorité des trois
cinquièmes au congrès mais dès 1973 la
question du quinquennat était posée et
dès 1973 la question de savoir comment
gérer un mandat de sept ans avec
l'érosion de la confiance populaire dès
lors qu'on renonce à la vision du
général de gaulle qui est celle de la
remise en cause de cette confiance
attaques régulières et bien été posé
cette question m'a été posée le général
de gaulle lui-même en 1967 s'était
interrogé sur la possibilité de ne pas
avoir de majorité
georges pompidou s'est posé la question
à la veille des législatives de 73 et
valéry giscard d'estaing vous le savez
s'était posé la question la veille des
législatives 78 dans son fameux discours
de verdun sur le doubs et ensuite le
problème a été réglé
si je puis dire par le peuple avec les
cohabitations les trois cohabitations
qui ont succédé
donc dès 1973 et ensuite la question de
la nécessité de réduire la durée du
mandat présidentiel s'est posé et l'eau
si l'on revient aux conditions dans
lesquelles on est passé au quinquennat
et donc à la façon dont le débat a été
lancé
et bien ce qui est intéressant c'est que
le principal responsable du quinquennat
c'est le premier ministre de l'époque
c'est le premier ministre de
cohabitation
celui qui pendant cinq ans va exercer
les pouvoirs de chef de gouvernement les
plus importants de l'histoire de la vème
république face à présent république
amoindri et réduit aux acquêts
constitutionnel de ce que lui donner les
textes et finalement c'est ce premier
ministre qui ambitionne d'exercer la
fonction présidentielle qui va mettre en
oeuvre une double réforme qui va dans
son esprit permettre à la fonction
présidentielle d'exercer une autorité
pérenne sans risquer de ne courir
la plupart des risques de cohabitation
on ne peut jamais les écarter
complètement bien sûr le présent les
arts l'a dit tout à l'heure il peut y
avoir une démission une destitution
un décès qui font que non mais où une
dissolution ratée mais en tout cas c'est
lionel jospin qui dès le départ propose
le quinquennat et qui lorsqu'il aura
fait voter le quinquennat et bien
proposera que la primauté du présent à
public soit assuré par la prolongation
du mandat des députés
donc vous le voyez c'est toujours
intéressant de voir qui est l'auteur
d'une révision constitutionnelle le
général de gaulle est l'auteur de la
révision constitutionnelle qui a
introduit le suffrage universel direct
pour l'élection du président mais en
ôtant il l'avait anticipé à travers les
référendums qui
v trois reprises promus entre 1958 et
1962 lionel jospin est le principal
auteur de la révision de 2000 qui
conduit donc au quinquennat et on peut
penser qu'il était quand même bien placé
pour le faire parce que c'est lui qui
pendant cinq ans va exercer les
fonctions de premier ministre et qui
arrive au terme de son de sa gouvernance
de premier rang se disant que finalement
la meilleure solution c'est quand même
d'exercer la fonction de présence
publique et de se donner les moyens de
pouvoir gouverner en ayant une majorité
qui soutient l'action du président donc
je crois que cela
c'est quelque chose que nous devons
avoir en permanence à l'esprit une
entrée un autre élément de la réflexion
que nous devons avoir c'est que dans la
proposition du président mézard il ya
quelque chose de nouveau car il ne
s'agit pas simplement de rétablir le
septennat
il s'agit d'introduire un septennat non
renouvelables alors dans la dans la
conception de des différents présidents
de la république qui sont succédé depuis
on a eu d'une part ceux qui étaient
favorables au quinquennat
georges pompidou jacques chirac
finalement ce qu'ils ont appliqué
ensuite
et puis il ya ceux qui étaient
favorables au septennat mais aucun
d'entre eux ne s'est prononcé pour un
septennat non renouvelable ni d'ailleurs
pour un quinquennat non renouvelable
rappelons nous que en 2000 lorsque la
question de la révision s'est posée
jacques chirac a accepté cette révision
à une seule condition c'est que il n'y
ait pas de limite à la reconduction du
mandat et que le président puisse être
réélu aussi longtemps que le peuple ait
lui-même d'ailleurs le jugerait utile
donc cette idée du septennat non
renouvelable n'est jamais venu à
l'esprit de ceux qui ont été en
responsabilité présentiel et je crois
qu'on doit quand même se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons la
première raison c'est que c'est au
peuple de décider
si on veut ou non garder un chef d'état
en fonction
ce n'est pas à des dispositions
juridiques de le prévoir de façon
impérative
et donc si le si le président se
représente d'ailleurs il peut toujours
ne pas être réélu la preuve c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing qui en 1981 n'est pas
réélu c est de toute façon c'est aussi
le fait que même si un président est
réélu il n'empêche qu'il se trouve
toujours face aux aléas de la vie
politique
donc cette idée de limiter voire
d'interdire la possibilité pour un
candidat à une élection de se
représenter
et bien c'est une idée qui était
étrangère à tous ceux qui ont été en
responsabilité depuis 1958 et ça je
crois que nous devons l'avoir bien à
l'esprit alors troisième argument la
question de la durée des mandats c'est
vrai que là la réduction du mandat de
sept à cinq ans elle n'est pas
simplement due elle n'est pas simplement
due à la question de la cohabitation à
les duos si on fait que dans la plupart
des pays démocratiques
le mandat de ceux qui sont en
responsabilité ne dure pas sept ans
alors bien sûr il ya le président
quelques président de la république
qu'ils sont élus pour sept ans
notamment celui d'italie d'ailleurs qui
se prépare à démissionner parce qu'ils
trouvent que partir pour deux mandats
c'est un petit peu le pont pour lui
surtout à son âge je le comprends mais
bon cela dit aussi parce qu'ils pensent
que les dangers qui menaçaient la
république italienne se sont éloignés et
que donc il peut rendre son tablier
mais donc ce que je voulais dire c'est
que lorsque on garde un mandat de sept
ans août sept ans renouvelables dans les
pays européens
c'est souvent parce que le titulaire de
ce mandat exerce une magistrature
d'influencé mais ils n'ont pas une
magistrature décisionnel dans tous les
autres pays
le mandat est moindre et même les
présidents de la république qui ont des
fonctions qui sont élus par le peuple
qui ont des fonctions beaucoup plus
limité que le président lacunes
françaises ont tous des mandats
inférieur à 7 ans est ce que le présent
mais arts nous a dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu' il ne faut pas aller dans ce
sens de la réduction du temps médiatique
mais je dirais que c'est la réduction du
sang du temps politique
ce n'est pas la réduction du temps
médiatique sachez une chose c'est que si
le présent et publics dans la plupart
des pays européens et élus pour moins de
7 ans
les députés le sont aussi pour moins de
cinq ans dans beaucoup de dans beaucoup
d'états démocratiques européens dans la
majorité d'entre eux les députés sont
élus pour quatre ans voire trois ans et
ne parlons pas des représentants de la
chambre des représentants des états unis
qui eux sont élus pour deux ans donc en
général la durée du président de deux
mandats du président est moindre qu'en
france la durée des mandats des députés
est moindre qu'en france et donc
l'organisation du temps politique
dans la plupart des états démocratiques
qui d'ailleurs ne fonctionne pas plus
mal que l'autre est bien n'est pas la
même donc l'argument selon lequel le
quinquennat aboutirait à amoindrir la
possibilité pour le président de
travailler sur le long terme
je crois que c'est un argument qui est
relativement peu pertinents un dernier
élément président mézard vous disiez
tout à l'heure dans votre présentation
de votre proposition de loi que la
question du travail utile pour un
président était fortement hypothéqué par
le sun quinquennat à partir du moment où
c'est vrai il est élu pour cinq ans et à
partir d'un certain moment on ne pense
plus quelque chose c'est être ring au
moins à la fin de son premier premier
mandat je crois que c'est un problème
qui n'est pas constitutionnelle
c'est un problème qui est politique et
qui tient à l'organisation du travail
politique
je vous donnerai un exemple j'ai la
faiblesse de penser et je ne suis pas le
seul que jacques chirac premier ministre
en 1986 pendant deux ans accomplis
davantage d'oeuvres législatives que
jacques chirac présent la république
pendant les cinq ans où il a été réélu
président pourquoi pour une raison très
simple c'est que lorsque en 1986 la
majorité législative est arrivé au
pouvoir
elle est arrivée avec un programme qui
était intégralement près et donc dans
les six mois qui ont suivi son arrivée
au pouvoir
elle a fait adopter la plupart des lois
qui ont été ensuite mise en oeuvre
durant les deux années qui ont suivi et
même au delà
alors qu'en 2002 lorsque jacques chirac
a été élu après une grande incertitude
pour savoir qui serait candidat qui
serait présent deuxième tour
rappelons-nous le débat de l'épaule et
bien le programme présidentiel et
législatif était loin d'être prêt et il
a fallu finalement suis subir un certain
décalage dans la dans l'élaboration des
textes qui ont été les textes qui ont
été finalement proposé au parlement dans
l'est dans les années qui ont suivi
donc tout dépend de la façon dont le
travail législatif s'organise ça n'a
rien à voir avec la durée du mandat
un présent à public peut être élu à
l'instant t est entré en fonction
immédiatement avec des textes
législatifs qui sont immédiatement prêt
et puis aussi on peut avoir le cas
inverse où un président est élu et on va
attendre deux ans pour que les premiers
textes sorte de façon significative
cela c'est lié à l'organisation du
travail législatif à l'organisation du
travail gouvernemental
ce n'est pas lié au mandat présidentiel
en lui-même c'est une question politique
alors je crois que il faut que nous
ayons tout cela à l'esprit
et puis il faut peut-être se dire aussi
président messin que la question des
pouvoirs du président ne sont peut-être
pas uniquement liée à la question de la
durée de son mandat et nous avons eu
l'occasion je crois en commission des
lois d'évoquer d'autres questions par
exemple la séparation des pouvoirs est
ce que le fait qu' il n'y a pas de
séparation des pouvoirs entre le fait
que le preneur public et le chef de
l'état et d'autre part qu'il est le chef
de la majorité du fait qu'il maîtrise la
dissolution du fait qu' il y ait un lien
étroit entre la majorité parlementaire à
l'assemblée et le pose en public
est-ce que cela n'est pas une question
qu'il faudra un jour qu'on y réfléchisse
or ce n'est pas directement
on est même indirectement liés à la
durée du mandat présidentiel
donc je crois que focaliser tous les
débats liés à l'avenir de la fonction
présidentielle sur la seule durée du
mandat
je crois que ce n'est pas prendre
forcément la question par le bon côté
merci beaucoup monsieur rapporteur mais
c'est jean marie le guen
les chiens ministre je vous en prie vous
avez la parole monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente bien sûr monsieur
le rapporteur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
nous évoquons cet après-midi un sujet
fondamental pour nos institutions celui
de la durée du mandat du président de la
république il s'agit d'une question
importante puisqu'elle met en débat
l'exercice de la fonction la plus
éminente de la république pour traiter
un si beau sujet je crois utile de faire
quelques rappels sur l'histoire de nos
institutions et les origines du
septennat dont le groupe rdse demande
rétablissement sous une forme non
renouvelable le septennat présidentiel
n'est pas le résultat d'une réflexion
théorique mûrement pesé mais en fait des
hasards de l'histoire c'est en effet
après l'échec des négociations entre
monarchistes et républicains sur la
durée du mandat présidentiel qu'une loi
du 20 novembre 1873 est venu confier le
pouvoir exécutif au maréchal mac mahon
pour une durée de sept ans il s'agissait
en fait d'une position de compromis
visant à concilier les partisans du
quinquennat et ceux du décès n'a dans la
tente d'une réflexion institutionnelle
apaisé décidé dans un contexte
tumultueux celui du retour de la
république le septennat fut toutefois
confirmé par les lois constitutionnelles
de 1875 puis par les constitutions de
1946 et de 1958 la constitution de 58 à
donner un sens nouveau au septennat
présidentiel
en effet sous les 3e et 4e république le
président n'avait rien n était rien pour
reprendre les mots
d'andré tardieu la vème république mis
fin à cette impuissance en donnant de
vastes prérogatives au président de la
république garant de la continuité de
l'état et de l'intérêt de la nation
arbitre placé au dessus des partis
politiques et représentants de la france
à l'étranger
dans cette optique le septennat avait
une justification théorique délier le
président de la république de la
majorité parlementaire ne faire reposer
sa légitimité que sur le peuple afin
qu'ils soient comme l'affirmait le
général de gaulle l'homme de la nation
mis en place par elle même pour répondre
à son destin c'est ce raisonnement
renforcer en 1962 dans les circonstances
que l'on connaît par l'élection au
suffrage universel direct qui compte 18
qui conduisit la vème république a donné
au président un mandat plus long que
celui de ses députés
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à dessein de
justification théorique du septennat car
en pratique le président de la
république a rapidement cessé d'être l'
arbitre impartial du jeu politique que
le constituants de 1958 voulu qu'il fut
dès le début de la vème république le
président est apparu comme le chef de la
majorité parlementaire et je m'associe
pleinement à hugues portelli qui
souligne dans son rapport que la
conception du président arbitre n'a
jamais été vraiment celle du général de
gaulle qui est intervenu d'entrer dans
les décisions de politique intérieure en
donnant ses directives au gouvernement
qui a interdit aux premiers liste de se
faire qualifier de chef du gouvernement
cette évolution était d'ailleurs normal
et prévisible élu grâce au soutien d'un
parti et sur la base d'un programme
politique le président la république
pouvait-il abandonner ses convictions
après son élection et se limiter à
concilier les opinions des uns et des
autres il n'était ni possible ni
souhaitable que le président soit placée
hors de la vie politique
ainsi en dehors des périodes de
cohabitation
tous les présidents successifs ont joué
un rôle non négligeable dans la vie
politique française
non seulement en contribuant à la
définit
sion et à la conduite de la politique de
la nation mais aussi en prenant part aux
débats nationaux lancés par le parlement
par la presse ou par les parties la
figure d'un président arbitres qui
seraient sans lien avec la vie politique
le fonctionnement des institutions
n'auront donc pas fidèlement compte de
ce qu'est le président de la république
depuis des décennies dès lors l'idée que
le président serait détachée de la vie
politique est une fiction et ne saurait
justifier que le chef de l'état dispose
dispose d'un mandat plus long que celui
des députés
ce constat ne date pas de l'an 2000
année de la révision constitutionnelle
sur le quinquennat
il est en fait beaucoup plus anciens dès
1973 georges pompidou avait tenté de
raccourcir la durée du mandat
présidentiel pour la ramener à 5 ans
comme le soulignait à l'époque le
sénateur etienne dailly le quinquennat
apparaissait comme la conséquence
logique de l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel
faute de suffrages suffisants pour
atteindre la majorité des trois
cinquièmes au congrès le projet de
révision de 1973 suis toutefois avorté
et ce n'est qu'en 2000 que le
quinquennat fut approuvée par référendum
par 73% des français
si j'ai pris le temps de faire ce rappel
historique c'est parce qu'il me semble
encore pleinement valable le septennat
n'est pas un sujet tabou et la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle du
président jacques mézard a toute sa
légitimité
cependant je ne m'associe pas à ce texte
et ce pour plusieurs raisons
même si comme a été soulignée par notre
rapporteur par votre rapporteur le débat
a vraiment toutes les raisons d'exister
et il fait progresser
une façon permanente notre réflexion sur
des questions qui se posent
indiscutablement dans notre
vide politique et dans la période que
nous connaissons même si elle n'est pas
le produit simplement d'une réflexion
théorique même si on voit fleurir
beaucoup aimé si elle est tout
simplement aussi l'expression d'une
réflexion sur la crise démocratique que
nous vivons et sur lequel est bien la
place des institutions est évidemment
questionner et leur fonctionnement en
premier lieu donc je reviens à mon sujet
le plus immédiat en premier lieu
rétablir à 7 ans la durée du mandat
présidentiel ne puisse pas la réflexion
que nous pourrons mener sur nos
institutions tout au contraire cette
réforme isolés pourraient déstabiliser
larchitecture des pouvoirs remettre en
cause un équilibre fragile le président
de la commission des lois
jacques larcher souligné dans son
rapport sur la révision de 2000 que les
effets indirects du quinquennat
dépendraient largement de la coutume qui
s'établirait à terre il en irait de même
pour le septennat non renouvelables dont
les conséquences devait être finement
mesuré en second lieu je ne crois pas
que les critiques formulées par le
président nezar sur le rôle du président
de la république dont j'ai bien compris
qu'il le considérait en quelque sorte
comme excessif est véritablement un lien
avec la notion même du quinquennat
présidentiel en fait l'accélération de
notre vie politique
surexposition médiatique du président à
république son rôle de chef de la
majorité
tous ces éléments n'ont pas une seule et
unique cause il me semble aussi résulter
d'une évolution de la société et du
contexte de crise économique et sociale
en tout cas de mutation que nous
traversons
si nous essayons d'aller plus vite ce
n'est pas à cause du quinquennat c'est
parce que les économies sont de plus en
plus indé interdépendantes
parce que l'information est désormais
instantanée et parce que les français
attendent des résultats rapides et
concrets
et si le président n'est plus prêt est
plus présent dans la presque par le
passé c'est aussi en raison des
changements récents qu'ont connu les
médias notamment depuis la création des
chaînes d'information continue
non pas à cause de la durée de son
mandat encore qu'on pourrait imaginer
aussi qu'il est la décision de vouloir
s'en abstraire mai
ce n'est pas la pratique qui est celle
des différents quinquennat que nous
avons connues j'ajouterai un dernier
point je ne pense pas que le sait telma
septennat non renouvelables répondent
aux attentes des citoyens déjà en 2000
la majorité s'accorder sur la nécessité
de renforcer le rythme des respiration
démocratique
au regard de l'importance des pouvoirs
confiés au président de la république
il est donc logique en démocratie qu'une
institution au pouvoir particulièrement
important reviennent plus souvent devant
le suffrage universel
allongé à 7 ans la durée du mandat
présidentiel
ce serait prendre le risque de
l'isolément de la perte du lien avec le
peuple
c'est justement pour lutter contre ces
risques que le quinquennat a été
instituée je pense également que
septennat n'est pas adapté au rythme de
notre époque déjà en 1973 etienne dailly
rapporteur du projet de loi
constitutionnelle visant à instituer le
quinquennat ben on se ferait référence
tout à l'heure résumé ainsi la situation
prétendre que le candidat à la
présidence de la république va pouvoir
proposer un programme pour sept ans cela
relève davantage de l'art divinatoire
que de l'art politique que ne
pourrait-on dire aujourd'hui dans une
époque où la conjoncture économique et
social peut connaître des changements
majeurs simplement en quelques mois
aussi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
comme vous l'aurez compris le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
l'adoption de la présente proposition de
loi constitutionnelle et estime que ce
texte tout en suivant des questions du
plus grand intérêt n'y apporte pas
ponctuellement à travers simplement
cette proposition une réponse
satisfaisante nos institutions peuvent
toujours être amélioré elles peuvent
être rendu plus efficace plus
démocratique plus adaptée aux défis de
notre époque et aux aspirations
légitimes des citoyens pour ce faire de
nombreuses pistes pourrait être en fait
mise à l'étude
le renforcement de la participation du
public à la prise de décision un
meilleur exercice parlement par le
parlement de ses missions notamment en
matière de contrôle du gouvernement
l'affermissement de l'indépendance de là
justice et il ya encore bien d'autres
sujets sur lesquels nous pourrions
intervenir cependant aucune de ces
pistes ne peut être pensée séparément
des autres limiter notre réflexion à la
durée du mandat présidentiel c'est
prendre le risque de l'inefficacité et
peut-être au pire celui de
l'improvisation je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
christian namy à la parole
ce sera le dernier intervenant je suis
désolé mais les quatre heures de
l'espace réservé seront épuisés et donc
je lèverai la séance à la suite de
l'intervention de monsieur lamy j'ai
bien de la chance
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
chez le rapporteur chaque collègue j'ai
bien de la chance qui aura pas d'autres
débats contradictoires la presse que je
vais t'emmener vous dire les français la
question qu'on peut se poser les
français ont-ils eu raison il ya 14 ans
d'abandonner le septennat pour adopter
le cas cana d'institutions de la
république a toujours posé la question
de la durée du mandat présidentiel
quelle que soit la conception de la
fonction à l'origine je le rappelle le
mandat du président n'était ni de cinq
ans neil sept ans quant à fonction chant
fut instituée en 1848 à l'avènement d'un
deuxième république
le président exerçait alors pour une
durée de quatre ans cette durée de 7 ans
fut le fruit d'un compromis boiteux
initiés ensuite par le maréchal mac non
premier président de la iiième
république ainsi que l'a rappelé le
rapporteur de la commission des lois
dame est témoin ce bref rappel
historique
les royalistes qui siégeait à
l'assemblée nationale était alors plutôt
partisan d'un mandat de dix ans alors
que les républicains pencher
majoritairement pour une durée de deux
fois moindre les premiers par sa longue
durée y voyait un mandat de monarque qui
pouvaient préparer une nouvelle
restauration les autres par une durée
abrogé souhaitait introduire une sorte
de dépersonnalisation dudit mandat afin
d'asseoir définitivement la toute jeune
république invité à se prononcer entre
le décennale
quinquennat maintenant on coupe à la
poire en deux afin de contenter tout le
monde ce qui fut le cas le septennat
donc étaient imposées davantage par les
circonstances que par un véritable
réflexion institutionnelle
néanmoins ce choix s'est pérennisée et
conforter non seulement par la pratique
initiale d'une présidence plutôt effacé
comme le soulignait d'ailleurs en son
temps raymond poincaré qui aimait à dire
au lendemain de son élection une seule
pensée m'habiter la terrible
responsabilité qui va peser dorénavant
sur - tandis que le principe de
l'irresponsabilité constitutionnel me
condamne pour sept ans au mutisme et à
l'inaction ensuite sous la vème
république cette pratique s'est
renforcée comme chacun le sait par la
volonté du général de gaulle qui a voulu
ainsi conforter le rôle et l'action du
président en effet pour le général un
mandat de sept ans permettait au
président d'aborder les grands choix de
la nation dès le début de son mandat
dont le cours seraient ainsi préservés
par la sérénité des dernières années
préserver à l'oeuvre à accomplir et non
la querelle partisane al partisane
pardon du renouvellement électorale
jacques chirac jugé ce système trop
anachronique et dégager des évolutions
politiques souhaitant mettre en place à
renouvellement plus fréquent du mandat
présidentiel et diminuer les risques de
cohabitation en alignant sa durée sur
celle du mandat des députés et a donc
fait adopter le quinquennat suite au
référendum du 24 septembre 2000 ainsi
que l'a rappelé notre collègue jacques
mézard seulement 18% à 55 des électeurs
inscrits soit 7 millions et demi de
français l'ont ratifiée dans une quasi
indifférence
l'un des changements les plus radicaux
de la vème république qui a profondément
modifié nature même notre république
en effet les 12 dernières années qui ont
vu se succéder trois quinquennats ont
montré que sur l'adoption n'a pas
amélioré en elle-même la démocratie et
encore moins la capacité de
contre-pouvoir au sein et en dehors de
la majorité après le quinquennat
chiraquien 2002 2007 celui de
l'hyperprésidence de nicolas sarkozy
entre 2007 et 2012
puis celui de françois hollande
actuellement en cours la question du
recours au septennat du retour au
septennat est revenue à l'ordre du jour
d'une manière générale nous pouvons
constater l'affaiblissement constant
l'autorité du président qui a pris les
deux après les deux premières années
mobilisés pour imposer les réformes
nécessaires se voit aussitôt confronté à
l'obsession du renouvellement électorat
on assiste aujourd'hui à une véritable
dérive de la place et du rôle des
institutions de notre république
confronté à une présente
présidentialisation excessive du pouvoir
et des institutions accompagné de
l'affluence grandissante des médias et
des nouvelles technologies de
communication dans la vie publique
politique
en effet la complexité des urgences de
la vie publique impose au président
d'avoir le recul nécessaire et de
disposer de temps pour mettre en
chantier les réformes structurelles de
l'avenir en dissociant la préoccupation
d'intérêt national à long terme des
querelles partisanes à brève échéance
électorale le recours au septennat
apparaît donc comme la meilleure
solution
sous certaines conditions d'ajustement
notamment celle d'un septennat renom
renouvelables c'est le sens même de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle que
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui à
l'initiative de nos collègues radicaux
de gauche visant à rétablir à 7 ans la
durée du mandat du président de la
république et à leur en ont
renouvelables proposition que je
soutiens ainsi qu'une partie importante
de mon groupe union udi u6 u7
permettez moi aussi de préciser qu'une
initiative identique a été menée par
notre collègue l'ump le député jean
pierre decool à l'assemblée nationale
l'objectif de ce texte est de
représidentialiser la fonction du chef
de l'état au profit du gouvernement et
du parlement au président de la
république la fonction d'arbitrage afin
d'assurer le bon fonctionnement des
institutions et la continuité de l'état
se tenant ainsi en permanence au dessus
la mêlée politicienne au premier
ministre et à ses ministres la fonction
de gouvernants de gouvernement met en
oeuvre le programme politique pour
lequel le chef de l'état est élu en
liaison avec le parlement le retour au
septennat est également une invitation à
venir
cette idée d'un équilibre entre les
principaux pouvoirs constitutionnels
politiques que sont le gouvernement et
le parlement
dans ce schéma le président de l'unfp
public sorte de pouvoir ne passait au
dessus des contingences politiques
seraient justement l'une des garanties
de cet équilibre à un moment où notre
pays a besoin d'une forme de stabilité
revenir au mandat présidentiel de sept
ans non renouvelable est une proposition
de sagesse débarrasser des
préoccupations liées à une éventuelle
réélection le président de la république
pour ainsi faire nécessaire travail de
réforme en profondeur dont la france at
on besoin c'est bon merci merci chers
collègues
voilà pour ce débat dessinateurs sur le
septennat non renouvelables débats qui
se sont tenus à mardi après midi au
sénat à la demande du groupe rdse ce
groupe à majorité des radicaux de gauche
vous avez notamment pu entendre jacques
mézard le patron des radicaux de gauche
qui portait cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle mais aussi par exemple
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état en
charge des relations avec le parlement
les discussions ont donc dû
s'interrompre car le temps consacré aux
demandes du groupe rdse était écoulée et
donc eh bien ce débat va revenir dans
l'hémicycle et sera inscrit
prochainement à l'ordre du jour par la
conférence des présidents
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances notre site sur
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires